here's a take destiny 2's story has
vastly improved over time sure but the
witch queen expansion has the best
campaign in destiny history yeah that's
right better than the taking king better
than our revenge quest for cage six
better than any expansion in destiny 1
or 2 so far keep in mind y'all this is
just my opinion and not our official
review our excellent guardian phil
hornshaw will have a complete review on
destiny 2 the witch queen coming soon
like this vid while you're here sub to
the channel be prepared for some
potentially minor gameplay spoilers and
let's dive in
what makes the witch queen without a
doubt the best campaign in destiny yet
is the structure of each mission add the
hive lightbearers the legendary
difficulty and some incredible
environments the result is you have a
campaign that rivals the golden days of
doom and halo
compared to previous expansions bungie
has made a big leap in the way it builds
destiny campaigns see destiny campaigns
have historically suffered from being
disjointed and lacking cohesion
particularly with the first game bungie
moved in the right direction with the
taken king and destiny 2 definitely
demonstrated learnings from past
missteps and flex its muscles with each
major expansion
there have always been incredible
narrative wow moments with any expansion
but until the seasonal model really took
over most of the story threads felt
disjointed this has changed recently and
with the witch queen we're finally
seeing bungie melding together some of
its best destiny design with the
improved storytelling from its seasonal
model culminating together into a story
that is engaging still what you should
know is that fans of destiny have been
waiting for answers to several loose
ends created from taken king all the way
through vanilla d2's ending
on this front the witch queen definitely
delivers the goods although not without
some confusing moments in line's shore
but that is all okay though cause like i
mentioned earlier the new legendary
campaign is an absolute home run from
bungie
for starters the loosen brood is one of
the best changes to destiny enemies ever
specifically the lightbearer acolyte
knight and wizard each has the power of
guardian super such as blade barrage
sentinel shield and stormtrans and boy
do they pack a punch if you've had
crucible nightmares of swarm grenades
and guardian supers man that ish is back
to haunt you in the campaign there's an
added level of adrenaline when you
realize that light bearers are basically
the equivalent to guardians and that
they can respawn and come back to life
after you kill them there is nothing
more brutal than whittling down a
lightbearer's health just forget about
its ghost and see it resurrect right
before your eyes
there's another minor benefit of the
light bearers depending on your opinion
on champions but the lack of champions
in the campaign especially on legendary
difficulty to me is a welcome one the
lightbearers are clearly serving this
kind of champion type replacement and
for the better however except for the
overloads i still personally like
champions i think is a smart way to push
restricted loadouts as a type of
challenge in the nightfall strikes but
fighting champions forces you to cycle
through gear and requiring that in a new
expansion campaign that wouldn't have
been smart the reason being we're
constantly getting gear drops both rare
and legendary so it's only natural to
want to test out all the new goodies to
your disposal out in the field and not
only that but champions kind of force
you to take them on from a safe distance
which is fine and it's still tense for
grandmaster nightfalls but it's not what
i want from a story campaign
this doesn't mean that the light bearers
give you the full green light to just go
in guns blazing you still have to be
incredibly careful
once you start dueling light bearers you
are forced to risk leaving cover to
finish off their ghosts once and for all
this creates a clever layer of fighting
where you're not only cognizant of how
to take these mini bosses down but when
you should take them down
throw in the hive wizard's ability to
create a healing rift or the acolyte
smoking you out with its grenade and
you've got a genuine challenge on your
hands
i find the light bears to be a
significant change in creating an added
layer of difficulty that isn't only tied
to a gear check the extra challenge of
the light bearers combined with the
incredibly varied level design and the
major encounters they work together in
tandem and all of this ensures you were
constantly wowed always moving to
another location that feels fresh and
never able to get fully comfortable and
safe from your enemies
if we were to describe the campaign
purely from mission length a single
witch queen campaign mission would be
about as long as let's say two to three
older destiny missions across any past
expansion not to mention plenty of older
destiny missions were painfully
predictable and aesthetically plain
the witch queen doesn't completely
abandon the core loop of traveling
across the expansion's new location
exploring areas fighting minions and a
potential boss but it doesn't prove it
the difficulty for the legendary
campaign scales meaning the more people
there are in your fire team the more
enemies will spawn bosses will also be
tankier and have way more health go solo
and you'll still be pushed and
challenged but with less overwhelming
odds this extra difficulty is not only
welcome but has a reward incentive
each mission has several major
encounters and completing these
encounters will give you two loot chests
seeing these chests spawn after a
particularly stressful boss fight feels
awesome and it's nice to know that the
game is respecting your time choosing
the harder fight so overall the rewards
feel appropriate
there's also an incredibly challenging
revive mechanic if you decide to take on
the legendary difficulty as a fire team
each guardian will only have one revive
token similar to how revives work in
darkness zones during the raids
once you revive a teammate you can't
revive anyone again during that fight
meaning jumping out of cover too often
or straying away from your team and
losing a token mid-fight can come around
to bite you there's also a timer
countdown on each ghost when a guardian
dies forcing your teammates to act
quickly and trying to snag the revive or
get wiped and have to retry the
encounter
it all adds a hectic sense of urgency
that can snowball into pure chaos with
dozens of already souped-up minions and
bosses chasing you down all as you try
to avoid the wipe timer
the new major encounters are also a
radical change from past destiny story
missions and take inspiration from
dungeon or even raid mechanics but in a
far more manageable form
each mission has a couple of major
encounters it may be an arena fight
while adjusting a cannon or completing a
ghost scan or battling hordes of enemies
while trying to unlock a sealed path to
your objective
meanwhile the parts between these
encounters involve a really interesting
amount of platforming that uses a new
deep sight system deep sight resonance
is basically the ability to see hidden
platforms or clues in the area for a
limited amount of time you activate it
at clearly visible spots and have about
a 30 second timer to find what you're
looking for or to cross the platforms
that it reveals adding an extra layer of
urgency to progress
deep side also makes the world feel
alive as you notice parts that were
formerly hidden such as footsteps on the
ground giving you hints on where to
search or seeing statues suddenly
pointing indicating you're on the right
path
lastly i have to gush about the visual
look of this campaign it is so damn good
for you eldon ring and from soft fans
yeah power yourself on the back the
aesthetic of those games are amazing and
their influence is clearly seen in the
hive architecture of salvation's throne
world i mean just
come on
in fact now is a good time to mention
that the areas in this campaign are
incredibly varied despite all being
situated primarily on salvathun's throne
world alongside current destiny 2
locations in fact it is so diverse
that all the footage you have seen so
far in this video has only been from the
first few campaign missions and this
doesn't even come close to scratching
the surface of some of the surprises
waiting in store in the second half of
the campaign
everything about this campaign has left
me in awe the revamped level design is
incredible the difficulty of the
legendary edition and the excellent
rewards feel great the loose and brood
the story beats the platforming the
puzzles the witch queens campaign just
feels complete
i can't believe i'm saying it but it
does
there was always something missing from
older destiny campaigns that felt like
you were going through the motions to
hit the end game as fast as possible not
really caring for what was going on in
the game world and just hoping to get to
the great gameplay of raids and dungeons
to be honest i went into witch queen
optimistic but ultimately expecting the
same so i was so caught off guard and so
happy that i deliberately paused and
took my time taking in every cutscene
interaction and major encounter guys i
literally didn't sleep the first day i
couldn't this felt like a triumphant
home run of a campaign and the only
frustration i have is that i need to
know what happens next in the story
right now
destiny 2 the witch queen is out and
we've got an excellent video breaking
down why it's a great time to play
destiny right now on our channel fans of
the game be sure to check out
gamespot.com that is where almost all of
our destiny content is at from guides to
breaking news especially deep dive lore
breakdowns and story catch-ups stay
tuned for our official destiny 2 review
by phil hornshaw in the coming weeks and
check out our game spot after dark
podcast as we'll have a spoiler cast
story breaking down discussions with
myself phil and jean-luc until next time
guardian
you